is there anywhere you can go in the  world where they don't know who you are  it happened when we were doing it I  think that's it no I think that's  something I remember once one one person  didn't know who I was yeah when did it  when did it nearly happen no I can't do  that  was some literally in some island in the  middle of the Caribbean in in of just  off Panama my dresser  um on the movie had gone out to this  island the week before and he got there  and he told everybody that he was James  Bond  I went there the following week and a  lot of members we could have like this  little plane and we landed on this  amazing place we went to who became  rushing when James Bond James Bond James  when they looked at me went oh  this is going to be a good day it's been  so surprised if they finally saw the  film